most people who hear of Lucifer they
think of a slithering demon coming to
get you from underground and pull you
into hell that's not what Lucifer is
Lucifer is the bearer of light it's the
Temptation it's the ego it's correlated
with our blood in the body it's the fire
it's the hyper spiritual it's the Super
Hyper religious it's being completely
disconnected from your Earth body and
connected to the fundamentals of what of
what Earth is it's being so outside of
your body and your thought that it's
becoming irrational
it's it's it's too spiritual to
comprehend that's the and you are the
Savior mentality you've seen it with a
lot of stories of people saying I'm the
Divine you know messenger you know I I
am this I am that and creating followers
and wanting to be revered as The Guiding
Light that's a luciferic tendency and
that's a Lucifer compulsion oh wow and
then on the polar opposite is the
aramonic energy which comes from ahraman
which is the deity from Zoroastrianism
that Steiner Steiner brought in that for
his cosmology which is the the deity of
materialism that you are only flesh and
bone that there's no such thing as soul
in your body that you are Earthbound and
aramon expresses itself through
government science materialism
all the things that are shrouded in
artificial intelligence computers
statistics all the things that we are
today and so today is the age of
Ultraman you know the last 2000 years
2500 years was a very luciferic realm
you can see it in all the stories you
could see it in the way that the
scriptures work and all these things
it's hyper spirituality over the last
four or five hundred years the aramonic
energy has made its way into our Earth
plane and Steiner 100 years ago said a
hundred years from now we are going to
be in the core impulse of ahraman and
we'll have 20 years to snap out of it if
we don't snap out of it in the next 20
years that's from 2020 to 2040 we're
going to enter something called the
eight sphere and the eight sphere is
something like the movie Wall-E or it's
a dystopic world where we've completely
forgotten what we've forgotten we have
no more connection to our soul as Graham
Hancock would say why are we uh why are
we a race of amnesia that's right the
fact that we have awareness that we have
amnesia means there's still something
there but you're saying that if we don't
make this transition by 2040 that we
won't even know that there was a past we
won't even have we won't be aware of
Amnesia that's absolutely correct we're
forgetting it through generations and
we're at generation lost right now and
it's getting worse and the Advent of
artificial intelligence technology data
capture which is pulling the child out
of the present and is not allowing the
child to develop internal faculties of
being in nature being connected to
Spirit which again goes back to
biodynamic farming and Waldorf education
and all these principles of developing
internal faculties based on the true
life as opposed to this fake radiation
controlled devices and this is the
system we're we're in desperate times
and it's getting dangerous and the
Christ impulse the Christ conscious is
the balance between materialism
and it's the middle way and Christ is
embodying that we are Earth bodies that
we have these flesh suits but also
knowing that there's a deep spiritual
embodiment and we have to understand
these Tendencies we've got to understand
araman we got to understand Lucifer and
not look at them as demons or being
scared of them or anything we have to we
have to study them it's the it's the
lack of looking at it and understanding
it that creates the problem and that's
what these two entities want they want
you to not know what that they are there
this isn't just random you know none of
this is random
what do you think is happening at that
macro level what is that macro level
manipulation I mean there's always lots
of theories about like you know the you
know Illuminati or cabal or various
different deep State and all those
things State yeah what's going on I
think they I think there's many names to
it
um so I don't think getting into the
what we call it it means much there is
an energy that wants control
that wants you know unlimited power
and that energy that
technocratic energy has
um mastered its next Evolution into
technology
you know there you could see it from the
age of Dawn and how it manipulated
different groups and systems from
Freemasonry to Knights of Templar to all
these things you understand it's like a
virus or a parasite it Taps into where
it can it can use its power Flex its
power and infect things and Technology
was the perfect weapon it was a perfect
weapon because you only once you
understand human psychology and
What Makes Us Thrive what makes us tick
what keeps us in a state of fear what
keeps us alive but not able to grow then
you can really manipulate the world and
you know the Advent of social media was
supposed to be the opposite of
mainstream television and but it's
actually become you know even a crazier
weapon and then you have handheld
devices and all these things and now you
have you know virtual reality and video
games and all this crap this stuff is
doing a number to us and so what is
their end game game I don't think
there's an end game I think it's a
constant game I don't think there's it's
it's it's anything that
turns into something else it just
evolves into where the world is taking
it and it's a it's it's it's rooted in
greed
it's rooted in fear it's rooted in
indoctrination
um and it's telling a fictitious story
that's where this and it's it's a
disease in in some form
so you don't think it's necessarily a
person a group uh you know a round table
of people it's it's more of a it's more
of a pattern within us like I mean I
think a lot about about a lot of things
being fractal and how while there's some
sort of Overlord macro sort of
energy that's trying to get us into
these negative spaces of materialism and
whatnot there's probably an aspect in me
like that too like in all of us
viruses are essentially how we've
evolved I mean it is because of viruses
that we are the human beings that we are
today and have the resilience that we do
and we carry I think ten percent I
looked it up because I wanted to know
more about this but like 10 of our DNA
is like altered by virus throughout time
and so
it's like this is sort of a different
manifestation but it's still
kind of like us still is that there's an
aspect of us that
is being realized on a macro level but
it's within all of us so it would lead
me to think yeah okay maybe it's not
like a a group
um or of this sort of like like I said
this sort of you know
Illuminating Illuminati group of 100
people that run the world it's just some
aspect of us and we have to figure out
how to evolve past it so that we can
energetically transition shift Elevate
our frequency and and enter a new Earth
I mean you said it perfectly I agree
with you one billion percent to claim
that there's a boogeyman behind the door
you know that's and and having fault
with that boogeyman puts us in that
state of Perpetual cycle
right you feel me on that totally yeah
you're exactly it's a victim mentality
almost it's a victim mentality and
that's powerlessness you're giving your
power to something else then why do you
think Holly weird is depict depicting
these types of movies since the
Inception of movies and film all that
stuff and the stories behind it it's the
boogeyman it's this evil whatever it's
this or that that creates this dualistic
lens that we're constantly going to be
held down by by something or we're going
to constantly have to fight this
something and that's part of this like
two-party system that we're dealing with
in this country the divide and conquer
it's all that same engineering problem
reaction solution you create a problem
there's a reaction you're provide the
solution to the problem you created it's
all psychosis we gotta snap out of we
gotta snap out of this and step into our
power and stuff or true sovereignty
that's the only way there's no other way
yes yes wow okay dots are connecting I
feel like this makes a lot of sense and
I think we can go back for a second
because you know we had sort of talked
about this offline a little bit with
school and whatnot but it you know I
love the saying that we are one
generation away from a solution right
like if we just get the Next Generation
to think differently to act differently
to be different we are we can really
uh we can really turn the ship we can
really auto correct for the future so I
think schools you know is something that
comes to mind and you know we were kind
of going off about this on our own but I
mean I don't have kids but I think I had
come from an interesting perspective
given the fact that I left high school
when I was 16 I got a GED I never went
to college yet I am a
successful educated intelligent person
that has good you know social skills as
well as like intellectual nature to
being able to digest information
um anyway and I didn't go to school so I
feel like while I don't have kids and I
don't I didn't really participate fully
it's because of it that I have this
ability to talk about it a little bit so
okay so school it seems like if there
was a solution it would be to to to to
go to that next Generation so what is it
that school does wrong and what does it
need to do right
I love this conversation and
school what an interesting term and what
an interesting connotation it creates
when just when you hear the word school
right the word magic behind it you know
school has always represented in the
last 60 70 80 100 years Higher Learning
it's also represented a club right
you're part of a club okay it's actually
a combination of The Higher Learning in
the club that allows you to be
appreciated in the real world because
the schools of is not the real world
it's just part of a process to get to
the real world and that we would
actually put ourselves in debt to go
through that process just just to
position us so the real world accepts us
right so without the school you're not
being accepted by your peers and by your
elders as someone that has the
discipline or has the where wherewithal
or comes from the family to put them
there so there's a there's a hierarchy
there there's a pedigree there thanks
everybody for listening to the pretty
intense podcast today I hope you enjoyed
it if you like what you heard today and
you want to hear more please click on
the Subscribe button